Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
(Musica)
Dalla sua pace la mia dipende.
Quel che a lei piace, vita mi rende.
Quel che le incresce, morte mi dà.
Morte, morte mi dà.
S'ella sospira, sospiro anch'io.
È mia quell'ira, quel pianto è mio.
E non ho bene s'ella non l'ha.
Non ho bene, s'ella non l'ha.
Dalla sua pace, la mia dipende.
Quel che a lei piace, vita mi rende.
Quel che le incresce, morte mi dà.
Morte, morte mi dà.
(Applausi)
(Musica)
Don Giovanni: Làci darem la mano,
Là mi dirai di sì.
Vedi, non è lontano.
Partiam, ben mio, da qui.
Zerlina: Vorrei, e non vorrei.
Mi trema un poco il cor.
Felice ben sarei,
Ma può burlarmi ancor,
Ma può burlarmi ancor!
DG: Vieni mio bel diletto!
Z: Mi fa pietà Masetto!
DG: Io cangerò tua sorte!
Z: Presto non son più forte,
non son più forte, non son più forte.
DG: Vieni, Vieni!
Là ci darem la mano,
DG: Là mi dirai di sì!
Z: Mi trema un poco il cor!
DG: Partiam, ben mio, da qui!
Z: Ma può burlarmi ancor!
DG: Vieni, mio bel diletto!
Z: Mi fa pietà Masetto!
DG: Io cangerò tua sorte!
Z: Presto, non son più forte,
non son più forte, non son più forte!
DG: Andiam! Andiam!
Z: Andiam...
Insieme: Andiam, andiam mio bene,
a ristorar le pene,
di un innocente amor.
Andiamo, andiam, mio bene,
a ristorar le pene,
di un innocente amor!
Andiam, Andiam!
Andiam!
Andiam, mio bene andiam,
le pene a ristorar,
di un innocente amor!
(Applausi)
Un buco nero è una massa compatta,
così schiacciata su sé stessa
che nulla può scappare
dalla sua tremenda forza di attrazione,
neppure la luce.
Un raggio di luce,
sulla sua superficie, resta lì.
Senza muoversi, senza riuscire ad uscire.
Congelato.
Niente esce da un buco nero,
tutto può entrarvi.
Don Giovanni è come un buco nero:
sfugge alla nostra comprensione.
Se ci limitiamo all'aspetto erotico,
lo banalizziamo.
Se lo leggiamo dal punto
di vista filosofico,
lo ingigantiamo.
Eppure, egli resta lì.
E come la superficie del buco nero,
attrae materia attorno a sé.
Non capiremo mai chi sia Don Giovanni
senza i personaggi
che gli gravitano attorno,
come per i buchi neri.
Dice John Weeler che "un buco nero
è come un uomo vestito di nero
che balla il valzer
in una sala poco illuminata,
con una dama vestita di bianco".
Sappiamo che c'è
solo perché vediamo una stella chiara
volteggiargli intorno.
E così per il nostro eroe:
non esisterebbe senza Donna Anna,
Donna Elvira, Don Ottavio,
Masetto, Zerlina
e non da ultimo, senza il Commendatore.
Don Giovanni è il simbolo
di quanto è di più vietato e indicibile.
Raccoglie attorno a sé, come un buco nero,
la materia del male,
della tracotanza, dell'eccesso.
E l'uomo da sempre tende
ad essere attratto dal male.
Il Commendatore, dunque,
non ha bisogno di tornare in scena
per far sprofondare
il libertino agli inferi.
La punizione di Don Giovanni
è faccenda troppo umana
per dover scomodare il cielo.
Bastano gli uomini, con la loro furia,
a punire in maniera esemplare
la propria occulta
attrazione verso il male.
Fino al punto di pensare
che è giusto punire un colpevole,
perché dia l'esempio.
Mozart e Da Ponte oggi ci parlano
di due opposte tendenze dell'uomo:
la fatale attrazione verso il male,
e la volontà di esorcizzarlo,
di vederlo con vergogna e indignazione.
Perché il cielo è pieno, di buchi neri.
(Applausi)